Man,
I had my hand down and he caught me sleeping,
so he caught Moody's Sheils a lucky shot.
He's not ever going to do that shit to me.
If I next time I'm going to get him or he can't move the slicks and miss and I
never seen that before.
I'm a train for next time he's getting gum.
I'm stop him.
My thing is even the wrestling,
what I always wanted to do as I wanted to tech fall guys in wrestling and tech
fall,
what that means is when you're being in someone by 15 points,
you have a 15 point gap.
They stopped the mat because it's basically a skunk like you skunked this guy.
Like he sucked at that.
You beaten them that bad.
They had to stop it.
That is my mentality.
That is always what I strive for and in 2011 I believe,
I'm not 2011 2009 I led the nation in Division One,
two and three Nai,
whatever in tech falls.
I think at one point me and Brent Metcalf was battling like every week I would
look and see who had the most tech fault.
It was me,
be him,
be me,
him and I had the most because that's my was my goal is I want it to skunk guys
because in their mind what it says is you can't fuck with that guy.
There's,
you can't hang with him.
There was nothing.
You can do it.
It didn't,
it wasn't a quick pan of lucky pin or or this like he destroyed you.
He just set levels apart and that's what I do even in fighting now I do the
exact same thing is I would much rather dominant you from start to finish.
I want to break you.
I don't want,
I want you think about fighting me again.
It's not you don't,
I don't want you to you.
I want you to say fuck no,
I don't.
I should know shit.
No,
he beat me everywhere.
He broke me.
He took something from me because you're going to think about it.
You only remember the fights you lose.
You don't like.
I've been so many guys in wrestling.
I can't tell you maybe 30 guys that I beaten wrestling.
I don't have no idea.
But the ones you lose,
you can almost tell everyone.
And that's what my take on it.
I want to dominate you so bad.
When you think about fighting me again.
You don't,
you say fuck that.
I'll pass on that Phi.
And so people were like,
Oh man,
this guy doesn't really finish guys.
But how many guys want to fight me again?
Not a lot of them.
Do you have one loss in MMA?
Yes,
I do one loss.
Right?
Yeah.
I have one last is my second fight.
Um,
uh Caceres I forget his name.
I forget his first name.
Um,
it's the cassette hoser is Jose cause there's,
there's no Alex Caceres.
Yeah,
it's Jose cause his name is Jose crosshairs alleys considered old,
I think his older brother.
Ah,
yeah.
And I'm man,
it was a,
I took the final like a two weeks notice or something like that because it was
like eight months in between.
I fought my first fight.
And I thought,
see,
that's the thing with Emmett,
with fighters coming in to MMA now this is a lesson to you guys.
Everyone feels like,
oh,
I'm just going to jump in and it's going to be peachy.
I'm gonna be getting fights every other week,
every other month.
No.
So I fought my first fight.
I thought,
okay,
this is great.
My career's kickstarting,
I'm going to be doing fight.
He's never used so often.
I went through 20 I 22 opponents within my first fight.
If I got the second fight,
because now,
you know as Google,
now everyone,
all froggies national champion wrestling.
And I don't want to fight that because everyone wants to get to the UFC and they
figure,
oh,
it's the best record.
You want to be undefeated to get to the UFC.
So nobody wants to fight anyone.
That's hard.
Right?
And so of course,
at that point I was a wrestler.
I could take anyone down to hold them down for three rounds and went fight.
So everyone,
no one wanted that fight.
So it was months and months went by.
And then that fight came about.
I was just like,
shit,
I'll take you and I'll be honest,
I never grappled before that.
I never did Jujitsu and so I figured I could rest on my way,
do all this shit like,
man,
fuck these guys.
These guys are all low level guys.
You know.
Look who I trained with a train.
We were shot Evans and these guys,
those guys can't touch me.
I get in a fight,
I throw a one to his legs are there.
I hit him with a one,
two boom,
boom,
double leg,
like live within 15 seconds.
Boom.
Threw him down full mouth and I'm kind of throwing punches.
I didn't really know what I was doing.
I'm throwing punches and I'm trying to elbow him and Jose could stereotype I
think six,
two,
six one one six.
I don't know.
He's well taller than me.
Long limbs.
He throws his legs.
I'm in full mount and he throws his legs around my body.
I never seen no shit like that before.
Right.
My mind at that time was like,
what is,
Oh shit,
what's this shit?
I didn't know what to do.
So I'm like,
so I started kind of panicking in my mind,
I don't know what to do.
I'm like,
fucking get out,
which is what you don't do.
Right.
So I turned my body,
I'm trying to like get up and walk out,
which is what you don't do.
And so he just basically climbed up my back.
Boom.
We're not even sweating yet.
He's on my back.
I'm standing up with a backpack on.
He's six,
so something,
he has a foot on the ground,
one foot wrapped around me.
He's fighting for the choke and I,
I think I hold them off for another like minute and a half.
I'm standing and I'm fighting this choke.
All the while I'm thinking like,
Oh shit,
I can't go down cause I don't know what the fuck I'm doing down there as well.
So I don't really know the defense down there.
So if I go down,
I just might make it worse.
I don't know the defense and this dude looks like he knows what he's doing
behind me.
He's got a few more,
he's got a few fights and I'm,
I'm kinda scared and I'm fighting it now I'm standing up,
my feet are getting heavy,
getting shaky.
I'm like,
I'm a strong guy.
What the fuck am I feet shaking because they're starting to fill up with blood.
My adrenaline is pumping and I'm just like,
Oh shit,
I'm about to lose
Joe.
There's this moment in your mind to it.
You start to come to realization certain things.
Yeah.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
I'm about to lose and what?
And then I start thinking about random thoughts and one of the thoughts that I
thought thought about was before the fire,
we had a commission meeting in the bag and the commission said if you get choked
unconscious,
you're suspended for six months.
So you can't fight for six months.
Because in my mind I'm like,
fuck this.
I'm a tough guy.
I'm,
you got to put me to sleep.
I ain't never tapping.
So I'm like,
if I get,
it took me eight months to get this fight and this is short notice fight.
I haven't made money in eight months.
I'm broke as shit.
I sleep and I live with Rashad.
I live with another man.
I'm broke as shit.
I have no money.
I need money.
So if I can't fight for another six months,
I have no money.
So all these thoughts going through my mind,
and I hear Alex Caceres on the other side of the case screaming.
He is gonna tap.
He's,
they're both out.
And I'm like,
fuck,
am I going to die?
I'm like,
fucking well-played Alex.
Now I'm thinking about to happen just for that shit.
Oh Man.
I just saw it going down and I'm like,
you can't be suspended for six months,
Bro.
I know you want to be tough right now.
You want to go to sleep?
What?
You can't be suspended for six months,
Bro.
You have to,
you gotta.
You know you gotta make money,
you're broke.
I fucking tapped Joe.
I've fucking dad.
I never felt so,
I don't want to say a masculinity if that's the word.
I never felt so like I just,
that's when I said like win or lose,
it takes something from you.
And I walked out of that fight.
I went to the back,
I paced for like maybe two,
three hours in the back.
All the fights fit,
finished up and I finally went to locker and got my stuff and came out.
But I just pace back and forth and the feeling and my mind was,
I am never going to feel like this again.
I do not ever want to feel like this.
And ever since then I got a fucking gate.
I never had to give me four.
I got a g,
I started training with George Santiago,
my you do to coach people to every fucking morning.
I was like Bro,
get your black belt after he came in my black Bra.
And this is the thing is I never,
I never worried about that.
I never worried about like yes I was freaking beaten up blue belts before I was
even a white belt.
Like yeah cause I never did that skill trained.
Did you choose to skills but like I knew how to grapple through certain things.
You know,
I've been grappling it hard at high level but it wasn't just Jujitsu.
So he kept challenging me,
like I was always cause I want to be that guy.
I want to be the freaking blue belt that freaking works.
All the brown and black belts.
But he would freaking promote me.
It's like Purple Bell because you've been training,
you trained in the G,
I'm gonna promote you.
So he kept challenging me and challenging them soul.
Now people knew.
I felt like all it was doing was alerting people of what to expect when they
went with me and for them to try to,
to really fuck me up.
And so he promoted me.
Um,
I think a couple of years ago I was a brown belt proponent,
I think maybe two and a half,
three years ago.
And um,
and then promoted me to black belt.
He just asked me to come in and gym.
I didn't really even know.
I just felt like,
okay man,
he wants everyone to take pictures with the bell and a fricking gives me my
blackbelt.
And other thing just floored me.
I was like,
shit,
I never knew.
I never expected all of this.
I just want it to fucking compete.
I just wanted to be a martial artists,
learn all this stuff and compete.
I never knew that I had to get a black belt.
I never knew that I would win the championship belt and be the best in the world
at this at that time.
So I never knew all that.